hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play paranoia AK
now with the success of witch's house
and how I was so surprised at how scary
and immersive the story was I'm going to
be playing more RPG horror games and so
I tried to pick one that was supposed to
be scary so I've heard that this one was
one of the scarier ones so I just wanted
to go with this so let's go yay I'm sure
it'll be a fantastic fun-filled
adventure this game contains sudden
surprises in harsh images those week of
harden those boar with Horrors should
not play author takes no responsibility
for any trouble that arises from playing
this game in addition this game uses
some discriminatory language and some
parts may be taken it's discriminatory
be aware the author has no danger to
promoting discrimination we play with
these advising x' in mind okey-dokey
it's been three years since my aunt
passed my aunt due to a certain turn of
events I moved into the house it had
been neglected ever since her death okay
this doesn't seem like a good idea this
place sure has gotten dusty I'm
apparently a beautiful grey haired girl
lady I suppose it was left for three
years instead of him I miss my golden
braids ah but oh well I'll take a look
around the house if you say so and I'm
guessing that I need to look at pretty
much everything in this game so I guess
we'll start with here it's locked
great the first door I go to is the
locked one Oh amazing place to start
okay I don't exactly know what I'm
looking for but I'm willing to bet
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that I
need to find because usually with these
RPG games um um
the puzzles may not always make sense
okay alright so anyway no know how to
save in this game II how do I save him
oh hello diary oh there we go okay save
oh there's a lot of stuff cool I have HP
I'm a novelist yeah yeah
no no Oh piss okay no one saw that no
what's up that's a good thing I saved
all right so anyone carrying on scoffs
tears see what's up here
anything hello hello anybody here no I'm
just going to kind of glance through all
the rooms I'm guessing that nothing
important is going to happen until I
find what I need to find it's empty
hello who the hell is that it's locked
it's locked it's locked
let me guess it's locked how many damn
rooms in this house or locked why would
they all be locked oh wait I know why to
make me run around like a [ __ ] see
nothing here nothing here nothing here
okie dokie it's locked it's locked which
way was this lock did I go in this one
it won't open it's probably locked okie
dokie sounds good to me
hello it's open there I know the phone
wouldn't be in the bathroom where's that
I don't know where the phone is coming
from hello teddy bear
are you the phone can I cut that teddy
bear arms up phone phone phone phone
phone phone where's the phone where's
the damn phone where's the phone
hello hello somebody phone someone want
to answer the phone
that was the bathroom shower phone Fung
Fung kitchen no phone
kitchen no fun over there phone there we
go and now it's Chaka Mora who is this
Oh Mickey you're there already how's
your new home why would she call if she
didn't think I was there very dusty but
it's nice and big that's good to hear Oh
your luggage should be arriving tomorrow
Thanks uh can I ask you something I've
been finding locked doors all around the
house you have the keys uh keys I don't
suppose I would she had quite a parsec
persecution complex
she even locked the doors in her house a
bit stupid if you ask me well do what
you can about it you can call Locks
Mississippi after well bye well alright
bye then rude okay so now what it's late
I'll take a
shower and sleep okay I know exactly
where the shower room is that's actually
one thing that I know in opposed to
everything this game that I do not know
barely doing anything I guess I'll just
take a shower okay no we get to see a
shower scene a a full pixelated shower
scene oh I don't get to see anything
it's all blacked out what is this crap I
paid for pixelated boobies actually I
didn't pay anything cuz this was a free
game so never mind guess I'll take the
guest room on the second floor I'll
sleep there tonight
okie dokie sounds good to me by the way
what's going on with your eyes lady they
look kind of sunken hello is it starting
already what was that sound the car rack
fell Arbour who did this Oh dead les ah
kill them dead listening
oh I found a key okay I don't know where
it goes I don't want to go hunting today
with Fitz I'll just go to sleep sounds
good to me I'm just gonna save because I
bet I just bet something bad happens as
soon as I go to bed in this bed this bed
here I don't exactly like sleeping in
someone else's bed but oh well it's a
guest rooms bed who cares right I'm sure
nothing bad will happen in the middle of
the night the hell is that why is it
drip-dropping is this the garage the
game
what the hell gonna why I don't like
these sounds okay alright then what the
hell was going on hello hi there how are
you doing good alright a dream probably
not I can't really remember okey-dokey
oh I forgot to take my medicine you mean
your crazy pills you psycho lady maybe
that's why I woke up I'm thirsty I'll
get some water in the kitchen
yeah great idea wandering out in the
middle of the night day one saving
bastok saver here all right what's in my
inventory a diary somewhere key medicine
for my illness what the illness is this
psychotic episodes okay water from the
kitchen why not water from the bathrooms
don't care don't care getting some water
perfectly normal
middle of the night kitchen nothing
Bad's gonna happen right mm-hmm
something bad happened whoa what what I
didn't see anything
what was it hair ill why is there hair
coming out of the kitchen sink huh hair
grows I don't ask questions
I'll have the water check tomorrow I
just want to go to sleep
yeah that's gonna happen I'm gonna say
it again
just cuz I can hello I didn't hear [ __ ]
I'm gonna go straight up to bed
hello hi somebody there I thought this
store didn't open a little bit oh yeah
sure I'll go in oh what's this what's
this stain Oh blood magazines and stuff
never came from magazines real magazines
magazines books books books books is
there something important here I'm
guessing only reason why I would open is
if I Oh sounds of it something in the
book a note hello they're trying to trap
me they hate me if I can't protect
myself from protecting myself the
password is SAE K I say ki
I'm sure I won't forget my own name sae
k i SI e ki okay found a no what good is
enough why did I need a know why I guess
that's it okay
alright then just go to bed I'm sure
nothing else
[ __ ] saver huh
what the hell is that what is that
what's going on why is I making that
noise it hello hi let's go they're
friendly
okay no I don't want I I don't want any
can you go away
no groan that's all you have to say lady
it's gross okie dokie oh god no I have
to run where should I hide I don't know
explain fleeing mechanics okay there are
various place I don't like those sounds
by the way pick a place to hide and hide
there before the monster comes in the
room okay the possible hiding spots one
is correct to our death and for the rest
you will be found that doesn't seem fair
playing continues until the right place
is found when the monster follows you
into a room you cannot hide there
he's time he flee the correct and deadly
hiding spots will change the chase will
begin now great alright then good I know
thank you no thank you no thank you
nothing you good
this is a Little Italy going here and in
in it did any good
lots of they died
damnit it found me he did not hear
someone else what do you mean I got a
second chance I thought that one would
end it dad was it that was bad
that was dumb I messed up God yeah I
don't like this game it's just upset
like there's no music
oh wait I'm here I need to save after I
get start to be tracked by this bastard
okay hurry up hurry up I got to run away
from you hurry up we're gonna hide how
am I supposed to know which place it's
the right place to hide that hardly
seems fair
you know what I'm gonna go downstairs
probably better than staying up here
yeah hi hi there hi friendly how you
doing how you doing buddy how you doing
you freaking weirdo monster scary person
okie dokie still don't I do not like
that it's after me I have to run okay I
got the fleeing mechanics can I say can
I say oh crap I can uh uh uh well if the
hiding place has changes how am I
supposed to know which one is oh my god
I'm gonna try the closet again lots of a
time here I'm sure nothing bad will
happen
ah not right
not safe what what the hell am I
supposed to do then
I don't know why why why lady man person
whatever the hell you are man hide in
the fridge okay
oh the fridge wasn't empty well shite ah
I am so bone just gonna be like ah I'm
bad at this I'm bad at this is gonna be
pure luck isn't it ah I forgot
oh they're crap crap okay who's here
who's here since I'm here let me closet
closet closet closet
damnit Baba why bother go I don't know I
don't know maybe it's like one spot in
the entire house is gonna be okay for me
I don't know ah crap I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what afford to do I don't know does it
do I have to just find one the one place
it's got to be okay for me to go into I
have no idea but either way ah I've got
to give this one last try and then see
where I go from there
okey-dokey running rod I that was way
too close okay not fair not fair not
fair in here in here in here where we go
where am I going in the safe the safe
okay
the fireplace it's in the room now I
can't hide well yeah bad okay
I'm a lot of time so maybe you guys want
to tell me what I'm father do there so
anyway this looks like it's gonna be a
pretty good game if I can just get away
from this guy
hopefully there'll be from different
scares eventually or else it's all gonna
be this one so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
and trying to move some immature houses
my chosen advisors Paul has decided to
hire some of you you're all great and
maybe some work fish now they are
pouring well tomorrow we will be tested
you steam
if everything is fine start master dad
also I got some new ideas for
human-machine maybe in the future I will
be able to make a mechanical you